if i want to go to an extreme to teach a
lesson
and file for divorce i could do that
it's my life
that's cardi b on twitter revealing why
she filed for divorce from offset
yeah to teach him a lesson oh snappity
snap snap
the pair is now back together but cardi
also had this to say
i know you got sick and tired of me
going back and forth with offset
because you know i'm just a crazy [ __ ]
but my thing is
i just hate when people start using
certain words
too loosely that it's just like bro
y'all sound
crazy like when y'all start using the
word abusive
i'm not in a physical abusive
relationship i'm not in a mental abusive
relationship
i clearly spoke to him i clearly okay
work things out little by little slower
slowly day by day it's crazy i i gotta
give you an explanation because i want
to make think pieces
of the that's going on in my home cardi
initially said she filed for divorce
this month because she was tired of the
fighting
i just got tired of arguing i got tired
of not seeing things
out of eye so before
when when you feel like it's just not
the same anymore
before you actually get cheated on i'd
rather just leave i've been with this
man for four years i've been i have a
kid with this man
i have a household with this man
sometimes you just want
you just you're just tired of the of of
the arguments of the buildups
but it was clear at her 28th birthday
party that they were on the road to
reconciliation
working it out yeah taking it slow
yeah we can see the family back together
i mean we're always gonna be
a family that's together
you